okay well good morning everybody
or good afternoon depending on what
times on your end
welcome to the bd2k guide to the
fundamentals of data science
I'm Michelle done i'm in the office of
the session Director for data science
its we please go to the next slide
um I just wanted to say a few things
about where we are in this series we
started with a wonderful talk by marc
newson in our early September that gave
us an overview of of really all of data
science and immediately jumped into
section 1 which was about data
management the data management is really
we heard about indexing and finding data
and within the data management section
but mainly about how to make data that
is usable so how how to make dats
well-curated falling standards for
metadata including provenance
information now we're into section 2
section 2 is um titled data
representation but really it's about
getting data into a usable format this
will take us through the end of the
calendar year and then starting next
year at 2017 will start up again with a
section on computing followed by a
second analysis and then other topics
like ethics but can go to the next slide
so here sorry I have a picture i should
be highlighting the section to data
representation which is where we're at
not computing but data representation
include topics such as databases and
data warehouses wrangling normalization
pre-processing those topics we have to
have two guest speakers because that
were two weeks in natural language
processing and exploratory data analysis
but today we are incredibly lucky to the
next slide
they were incredibly lucky to have with
us dr. an adventure ski who is
currently at UofT and has a background
in both neurophysiology and
bioinformatics she trained in
neurophysiology it at UC Riverside and
at stanford on she is the founder and
CEO of my crunch in addition to being a
part of that myth the neuroscience
information framework and she works at
the center of research at a biological
systems at UCSD on these two things myth
and by crunch and since I class work
together in order to a great vast
amounts of data though she's really an
expert in this area of telling of
knowing what to do with the data so we
really look forward to her talk or I
look forward to talk and I really really
appreciate and we all really appreciate
that you are taking the time and dr.
Andros gate to come talk with us today
and so with that of i think please take
it away
the floor is all yours
thank you so much and I really don't do
nothing but women are ok and what i will
do in just a second switch over to my
slide deck and i will then
mute my speakers so if you need to get
ahold of please do so in the in the
message box and so I think now we will
have a better clear and risk and voice
so I in this guide to the fundamentals
of data science as Michelle had pointed
out very and pointedly this is an
overview of data representation and I
have worked on the neuroscience
information framework for about 10 years
and the goal of that particular project
at university of california san diego is
to make as much data available in useful
to two people mostly to neuro scientists
and so many of the examples that I will
use will actually be from that
particular project but I do also
recognize that there are some core sort
of fundamental things and that happened
so in terms of the overview of data
representation of the lecture series
will cover things like types of
databases databases and and data
warehouses were very apt I think it's
wonderful we have a wonderful I list of
speakers including a doctor check
tomorrow also used to be up to up the
road from us and at the supercomputing
center dr cohn and i am going to picture
dr. have a higher values name and some
of the others but i wanted to point out
when these lectures are and what are the
sorts of things they're covering today I
will cover in a small amount of detail
kind of the basics of databases the
basics of data wrangling and then I you
should be able to know a whole lot more
from dr. borrow and and others
ok so one of the very basic questions is
what is data and I just wanted to make
sure that all of the vocabulary terms
are definitely you know have definitions
as this is supposed to be kind of a
primer lecture so data is the facts and
statistics collected together for
reference or analysis will also refer to
metadata which is data about data and
and actually when you think about it one
person's metadata is another person's
data so then you can have metadata of
metadata and it can go on from there
I'm but another term that I think you
should know is what is this schema and
it's basically the structure of the data
what does it look like and this has a
very set of specific meetings when you
start to talk about databases when we
look across biology data is incredibly
diverse and again this is one of the
examples from neuroscience but you can
substitute this the brain into a kidney
and to a liver into whatever else you
might want to look at
and essentially the problem is
extraordinarily similar by all I just
think about interactions of very very
tiny things they look at mr they look at
other aspect rasta peas they look at
data types of that sort on Brownian
motion and they look all the way to the
interactions the social interactions of
animal hurts and in fact there is a fun
study published by a group of ecologists
also biologist I'm you know point trying
to figure out how to use google maps to
determine whether count a cow's point
mostly north-south or east-west when
they organized themselves in Hertz and
they look at everything in between so
they're looking at intracellular
currents they're looking at MRI images
they're looking at latency to button
presses and all kinds of other things so
the data that comes from all of these
different techniques can be incredibly
variable so really biological data is
characterized by diversity because it
can be text there can be time-series it
can be categorical there can be images
that can be video there can be locations
geo locations and locations within the
body and all of these things actually
are data and their data for different
biologists but when we look at data type
it's a little bit different than that so
when when am I was trying to prepare for
this lecture there was this piece of
data on my desktop and so here it is and
there's applications specifically to
clone quality and quantity type and when
a biologist looks at this particular
piece of data
this just happened to be on my desk last
week um they might start thinking about
what this data actually means
so one of the things that I've learned
by being part of the neuroscience
information framework is that biologists
think about data very differently from
computer scientists and biologists tend
to imbue the data
meaning so what does it mean to me well
application WB ok that's western blot so
i did an antibody that works for western
blot clearly this is a piece of data
about antibodies and and these are some
of the things here in in the pink boxes
that a biologist might think about when
they see this piece of data but if
you're a computer scientist or a data
scientist you might start thinking about
this same piece of data the same exact
spreadsheet slightly differently they
might need to think about what the
structure of this data is that there is
an if' comma WB this is a comma
delimited list and they might think
about the specificity not as something
that I might or might not use but
they're actually thinking about well
what is the external look up that will
be required in order to explain this
specificity better this is actually a
look up to ncbi gene clone number there
a little bit confused about because this
is free text quantities and quantity
types they're thinking about the types
of operations that they might do on data
that is a that is numerical so data type
is a particular kind of data item
defined by the values it can take
whether it's text or number and the
programming language that's used for the
operations that can be performed on it
so again we can do things two numbers
that we cannot do it lists and so if we
look across disciplines it's not the
same thing
so when computer scientists look at data
they imbue it with structure and data
types I've listed some here there are
many more of these come from sequel data
types are obviously text controlled
vocabularies which you heard about from
from dr. mucin and actually dr.
sandstone and others and there are gene
names which this you know these are the
sorts of things that are the free text
there are numbers all kinds of different
types of numbers and and there are of
course
dates and other things but why do we
care about data types turns out the only
time you really deeply care about data
types is when you want to put data into
a database and a database is essentially
a structured set of data that's held in
a computer especially one that's
accessible in various ways so really to
understand what a database is I wanted
to go back and just ask what are some of
the things that a database can do
it's essentially a container for
different types of data its container
for data files you can think of it as a
file system on your computer so our
little example here for the this little
of this spreadsheet of antibodies could
be part of a database as long as it's
accessible on the computer so what are
the kinds of operations that I could do
and if this was part of a database
well I could do things like count the
number of rows that have a Western bloc
that are like Western bloc so which
which antibodies work for Western bloc
you can get that and it would be the
answer would be all four of these and
you can select rows were specificity and
actually is one of these zinc finger
proteins or the other one and then it
would bring you back the data about that
particular row or that particular data
items depending on what you asked you
could find all rows where quantity is
larger than or smaller than a particular
value so essentially the database is a
container it is a container that's very
useful in many ways in order to ask
questions about a particular data set
but you can do this as a biologist and I
bring this this piece in to this
overview lecture because most biologists
use Excel and excel is an incredibly
powerful tool and most people know all
kinds of things about Excel it is one of
these programs it's incredibly powerful
incredibly ubiquitous
but also every tool has its limitations
so I wanted to make sure that whoever
doesn't know about these limitations
knows about them after this lecture so
one of the limitations of Excel is size
right so there's a certain number of
points data points to a certain number
of data rows and data columns that Excel
will take and it is important to
understand if we have a data of a
certain size of a certain number of rows
that simply would be too large for excel
to take and so it's it's one of the
limitations that everyone needs to be
concerned about and aware of of Excel
the most recent and actually for the
last probably 5-10 years and versions of
Excel I've been getting more and more
aggressive in terms of auto correcting
and so autocorrecting here in this
particular article this is now quite old
but it hasn't changed so we should
continue to be aware of it is that gene
names that are actually become dates so
this is something that my excel did and
i have the latest version of excel on
running on a mac and so what this is
doing as I put in the APR for gene and
as soon as i hit enter it became the
fourth of april and and the way that
that's coded in Excel is the number 42
464 so if i put in a thousand genes into
my particular spreadsheet at some of
them were APR four genes then I would
have a very large mistake in my
spreadsheet and this is certainly been
called out in this paper and many others
so it's something that one must be aware
of that other problem with this is that
when you change from an excel sheet and
that's actually in a mac to one that's
in a pc and so you're passing a file
over to
to your graduate student your pee I your
fellow at whatever institute and they
happen to have a different operating
system in a different version of Excel
what ends up happening is that mistakes
like this which now become coated so
April fourth becomes coded as this
particular number that number is only
April fourth for a pc or it's only April
fourth for mac it will not be the same
number if you switch operating systems
so in a sense it is a really bad idea to
handle a lot of data especially large
data where there are genes involved on
Excel it is an extremely a bad idea
because there are these no differences
between the dates the date columns and
and how Excel actually handles them
this is another type of mistake that is
very common so here I've taken the CNF
622 gene and instead of copying and
pasting that gene I just dragged down
and you know that the little icon and it
actually the newer versions of Excel
again will not only iterate by one
number when you only have a number but
they will actually iterate to add one
number to almost any column that has a
number in it so this is another thing
that one must be aware of and I see a
lot of data and this is the kind of
mistake that I see and unfortunately
quite often
okay um so how can i really understand a
database so again in order to get
biologists to understand what computer
scientists are thinking and I wanted to
bring in some of the things that
computer scientists really be and data
scientists would be actually concerned
with when they see our file so computer
science is very very very very concerned
with efficiency of data retrieval with
the size of the total file with the data
types which we've just discussed
and with the types of operations that
need to be done on that data so this
particular excel file actually i have
saved it on my desktop in different
formats and this is something that we've
all done and I'm sure that all
biologists basically you know largely
ignore this and there's unless there's
some reason to pay attention to it so
this particular file is a 646 kilobyte
excel file saved as a latest version of
excel if i save the same information as
a PDF it actually becomes a 12 kilobyte
files you can see that there's a very
large difference but as CSV or text it
actually becomes much much smaller so
that really reflects something that
again for most biologists we don't care
my computer is large enough to handle
any of these kind of files but the
larger the file size you have actually
the more you have to care about this
sort of question these sort of ideas so
and again understanding a database is
really taking this particular example of
this file and we what we can see is that
computer scientist because they are very
concerned with the process of efficiency
of data storage efficiency of data
retrieval and the size of data they have
driven these spreadsheets down from you
know a hundred and fifty three bites to
even smaller and smaller sizes so that
you can actually store much more data in
the same space and one of the ways and
that actually this happens is through a
process called normalization of data so
here I've normalized this particular
table the one in yellow into the two
tables in in green and that the column
I've normalized is the specificity
columns so here you will notice that
there's a zinc finger protein here
there's a different one here and then
there are 22 rose Frizzle kindnesses
zip kinase I'm sorry and now the way
that we can make this spreadsheet even
smaller is actually to code the fact
that zinc finger protein 622 is actually
now corresponding to the number one the
other zinc finger is too and then these
two zip kindnesses are both three and
now there's something called a key value
pair so the number one corresponds to
this number to this number three this
and what that does over millions of rows
is it further decreases the size of the
data which is great
it speeds up a retrieval of data which
is great but the more rows and and the
more columns that actually look like
this the more data that looks like this
the less readable it is by a human this
spreadsheet i would argue is relatively
well readable by human but once you
start and changing out a lot of the
actual labels with numbers
what starts to happen is that you can no
longer read it you have to do a lookup
for each thing and those kind of
operations to make the the spreadsheet
back into something that's
human-readable really starts to take a
data wrangler and I'll talk a little bit
more about this
so what I'm talking about here are a lot
of relational databases now relational
databases the way the reason that i'm
talking about them is because they
handle very large files very very well
so you don't have to stick to just a
million rows of data and these are some
of the oldest and the most common
databases throughout the internet they
run banks they run stores they run all
kinds of transactions they run many many
websites everywhere you have a box you
probably are filling out a form that
goes into the database so we have a lot
of interaction with databases even if we
don't necessarily know that we do and
they do allow multiple users
including multiple machines to actually
add data simultaneously to the same data
store and they allow data to be
extracted at the same time as its put in
there are lots and lots of things that
people can do with these there's a
tremendous amount of diversity in terms
of what can they be programmed to
actually do and there is of course a
programming interface which makes
everything very flexible but as every
tool it is very very understandable that
there are some limitations so one of the
first limitations for biologists
specifically is that these kinds of
databases are actually more difficult to
set up an excel file or a google doc
they it is more difficult to do some of
these simple operations like copy this
data into that particular space and
there's no undo button there's no
autocorrect and which is you know either
limitation or high benefits depending on
where you sit and they are very
dependent on data structures so you have
to predefine what you want to actually
have in the database before you can
actually fill in the data so this is
something that's that is a limitation
that many computer scientists have
actually considered as a very
significant limitation and and they have
created a whole bunch of new types of
databases which essentially are much
newer less common and most of these
databases these data base types are
haven't been created to solve one of one
or more of the shortcomings of the
standard traditional relational
databases and so neo4j for example does
a lot of very efficient computation on
graph structures and I think that will
be covered by dr. borrow and others
mongodb does really wonderful things
with text storage and retrieval and
being very very much more efficient than
the conventional sequel databases but
new tools as all new tools and have
smaller numbers of people that can
support them
and not all the kinks are usually worked
out from a lot of these newer databases
so when you're choosing how to store
data it's important to consider some of
these things and not just always go for
the newest best thing because there may
be some lakhs of support so really I
wanted to ask the question what makes a
database useful to biologists so and
this is something i've i've run into and
and my colleagues have run into and
because I am trained as a biologist and
I see things from IC data from this
perspective quite a bit so what computer
scientists think that biologists want to
do with databases is actually quite
different than what biologists actually
want to do with databases and so one of
the things that computer scientists
often think is that biologists are just
dying to create hypotheses based on you
know and here i have a you know I have
pointed out this is a gratuitous graphic
and figured it wouldn't be a big day to
talk without one of these lovely hair
balls now this is zach lovingly referred
to as a data hairball and now computer
scientists really think that biologists
would love to create hypothesis based on
data now I haven't run into many
biologists that actually would like to
do this mostly they have a hypothesis in
their head already
that's based on reading literature and
and understanding biology but it would
be really nice if we could do that in
the future i'm also comparing their data
to other people's data biologists have a
really hard time doing that it actually
it's one of the things that biologists
are really reluctant to be able to do
and exploring data space is one of those
things where it's nice but it often
doesn't go right into the middle of the
biologists our pipeline in terms of what
they're doing in the lab actively what
biologists actually use data for
databases for is they look up papers
now I haven't been able to find the
exact numbers but in terms of the
internet traffic to biological databases
but i do know from various sources that
the vast majority and this is a very
very high majority of all web traffic to
any database in biomedicine actually
goes just 21 if that one is pubmed that
is a database and it is where everyone
goes and biologists do share data and
they store data in databases but they
often don't look for data they're my own
traditions do and so that's a whole
different story but biologists tend to
just take their data and put it
somewhere and they need to make sure
that that's relatively easy biologist
also are starting to use databases as a
lookup so for example ncbi gene I need
to store my data I need to figure out
what other gene is related to my Jean it
is my snip in this place or in that
place
what are the place it and who else has
published on that particular snip so
there's a lookup function but for the
lookup function you need to understand
the database has to be relatively
complete it has to be relatively
complete so for biologists actually use
a particular database as a lookup
function it has to have that that
completeness I'm unless it's useful as a
storage device in which case and there's
no no question there and completeness is
not necessary and so how many databases
are there currently for biologists and i
have tried to look at some of these
numbers and then I try to do some
lookups in both WorldCat so this is the
library catalog of resources including a
whole section of Internet resources and
and what they had is about 5,200
databases but this covers all filled so
it's you know geology and everything
else and I in the neuroscience
information framework we've cataloged at
12
six and 2600 of them essentially so
these are all biologically relevant
databases or largely biologically
relevant databases and so that's the
kind of thing that we're looking at at
NCBI which is the national library of
medicine there are a hundred and fifty
databases that are housed actually
inside of ncbi of course everyone knows
pubmed and most people know pubmed
central but there is actually a hundred
fifty others including some that you
probably know and many that you've never
heard of but i would are you know I
encourage all people to kind of explore
some of these and these other databases
are a TBI 53 and databases are actually
housed including europe pubmed central
so a way to get articles from for
Europeans array express which is very
similar to the Geo campbell and others
and but the biologists my task with all
of these different databases and and
here I've actually put pulled out some
of the keywords from the neuroscience
information framework system and for all
databases and the organisms that have
been tagged to those particular database
entries so essentially if you're a
biologist and you're looking for a human
genetics database you will have hundreds
to choose from hundreds right so if you
have the choice of trying to find your
data in hundreds of databases or
thousands of databases you might ask
some questions as a biologist how many
of these are still alive how many of
these are still being added to which
ones are being cited which ones are
being used which one's house actually
the same data so we know that array
express and geo actually has many of the
same data sets which ones with the gold
standard where do I put my data so that
it gets saved and kept and this
particular question is not just being
asked by biologist but it's also being
asked by the journals because the
journals need to ask the question
okay I have an author who has a
particular type of data where do i send
that author to deposit that data we know
that depositing the data is important we
want to go can't go along with the
standards that are being put forward by
the granting agencies but where do i go
there are 2600 databases that might be
relevant to them which ones are the ones
i should actually point them to computer
scientists actually look at the this
this landscape and think other thoughts
they think well which ones are
relational which ones are mongodb base
which ones you know have this or that
kind of scheme at how can i get data out
of this this or that one and they're
looking also its standards and which
ones are structured in a particular way
and again Suzanne samsung and I i would
encourage you if you had seen the last
lecture to to see the last lecture in
this series and what she did a very nice
job discussing some of this in terms of
the standards of databases that are
being used and through bio sharing and
so if I'm a biologist there are 30
database is relevant to me how do i
navigate and query this number because
we have to remember databases are not
completely standard in fact they're very
likely to not be very standard right
each one has its own interface each one
has its own organizational system each
database has its own caveat which
database may reference a completely
different standard in terms of how it
stores its data so how do i navigate
this this mess essentially and this is
where we actually have to learn about
the data warehouse and the data
warehouse is essentially a whole bunch
of databases put into one system so that
somebody can run a query across those 30
databases but of course in a data
warehouse what we can actually start to
do is we can ask questions of all these
multiple databases we can ask a question
such as
which Parkinson's disease causing snip
this clear clinvar house that may have a
homologous mutation in a worm
this is something that can be asked of
three or four five databases together
but not of anyone because one database
may not have all of the right links all
of the right connections to ask that
sort of question so a data warehouse
starts to broaden the scope of a
particular database and truck starts to
connect the different databases and
based on different rules in terms of how
a particular set of data can interact
with another set of data how can a
particular database talk to another
database and what are the sorts of
things so here I've actually i'm showing
you an example of a one data warehouse
system and this data warehouse system
actually that the thing i have
highlighted here is the strain data and
the RIT strain data for for worms for
this is at war base a table from which
talks about the genotype of these
particular and cl against and within
this particular database which is a data
warehouse
there's a lot of other data including
neuron DB there there's data on from
were mine there's data from homology
there's data from all of these other
databases but then as soon as you start
to hold this amount of data in this kind
of data
the thing that happens is you're very
very concerned about when that data
actually came in because it might be old
what were the data transformations so
there is something on unworn base now we
made some assumptions in order to create
these particular tables those
assumptions need to be absolutely
explicit those are data transformations
that happen
but between what were basis and what we
say we're basis right and so there are
these assumptions that are made there is
a Providence in terms of when the data
entered our system when the data was
released from a on underwater base site
is another set of a Providence right so
there are a lot of things to know and
these are metadata about the particular
database table that you're looking at
what am I looking at very important to
know so these are all very meaningful
things that need to be answered
so when you do this though
let's say we want to put together 30
databases each day tomato base makes a
lot of different assumptions about the
data if I want to do this myself in my
lab will my programmer computer science
colleagues actually deal with the kinds
of complexity that a lot of these
biological databases house and contain
will i be able to interact with them
well enough to get them to understand
what it is that the data actually is
supposed to mean
so that the structure can reflect that
properly so data wrangling is a sort of
a you know it's been it's a term that's
been thrown around quite a bit but it's
starting to actually we're starting to
have an understanding of what a date
data Wrangler is but in terms of what is
it it's a process of extracting data
from both tools databases and basically
putting it into your tool or database or
warehouse so it's a data stewardship
function but if we want to look at the
job description what must this person
really know if you have a data wrangler
what must they know well this is a fun
job description
this person must have a deep deep
knowledge of the meaning of the data so
PhD in biological science really helps
because that person would be expected to
understand the caviar
that data deep knowledge of clinical and
genetic databases each of these
databases again has its own caveat it's
they all take a certain kind of data
they don't take other data it can be
queried in ways that others cannot be
queried data structures are also very
important to understand for this person
so computer languages statistics L&R are
all really really important as well as a
knowledge of ontology the deeper the
better so the kind of person that that
needs to and do this wrangling is the
person that sits between computer
science and biology that person must
have a deep understanding of all of the
ways that biology has of dealing with
the data and all of the little things
that can go wrong with that particular
data and of course the computer science
which is the structure how do you now
pull this so that it's properly
structured into a warehouse so the kinds
of things and that biologists do which
end up having to deal with a whole lot
of wrangling of data and there's a lot
of data Wranglers over at other and
Craig Venters company human longevity
which just produced this very nice paper
in proceedings of the national academy
where they've just released the deep
sequencing of 10,000 human genomes you
can imagine this 10,000 data points
I'm for each particular genome and each
genome will have many pen many impending
many many millions of data points in and
of itself so making sure that getting
and getting that right putting
everything into one single warehouse is
actually the work of a large number of
data Wranglers ok so let's let's kind of
take this down into into a more
understandable level
ok so if we think of data wrangling as
as laundry doing laundry right there
there are these terms called manual
curation so the way that
we can think about data wrangling and if
if we were thinking laundry terms is an
alteration is sort of sorting everything
into appropriate piles and there's
something called semantic mapping and
semantic mapping is assigning the proper
word right to each of the piles
so here we have shirts in one pile and
socks and another pile so these are two
charms
now these piles are semantically mapped
there's automatic indexing and I think
you heard a lot about that previously
now there are we know that there are 10
shirts and five stocks wonderful and
there's a resource identifier so the
resource identifier is something i also
want to spend a little bit of time it
because that's how we can trace back to
what we actually have in the data
warehouse so if we look at symantec
mapping first semantic mapping is
essentially adding a term to a
particular data item and there are
different ways to do that again marc
newson and and Suzanne son had actually
done a lot of the work in terms of
explaining an ontology and turn
explaining how some of these
terminologies get put on two different
data systems so i'm not going to talk
about it a whole lot here but an
ontology is essentially a very very
structured glossary right or thesaurus
it starts to its it's essentially a way
of saying this is the thing that I'm
talking about and the semantic clarity
of an ontology is very very high
compared to even a taxonomy a taxonomy
is something that we understand we know
that mammals are related to rats and we
know exactly how they're related because
there are different steps in between
those two terms right but an ontology is
even better than that so for example
here when we look at an ontology of
socks
we know that Sox a sock is a type of
clothing and clothing to typically has
part thread right so these are all terms
that can be related to one another
now if you say I'm going to label my
particular set of data with the word
sock
now if i do it with just a controlled
vocabulary that's great because then you
can find out sucks but if your database
has thousands of different items or
millions of different items maybe you
want to look for all things that are
clothing and if you want to look for all
things that are clothing if you mark
your data with a controlled vocabulary
that controlled vocabulary doesn't know
that suck and shirt is related that
controlled vocabulary doesn't know that
stock and shirt is a type of clothing
but if you mark with an ontology those
relationships are inside of the system
of tagging which means that what you can
actually do is you can ask a database or
a database system for all clothing and
i'll show you some of that in a little
bit
well not with clothing more of the genes
but ok so when we also look at and think
about the stable unique identifiers this
is a really big deal there's actually a
big conference coming up in Iceland and
next week but here is a set of numbers
that you may or may not recognize there
is a telephone number and in my
telephone I see that number and it has a
little translation i used to be able to
remember these numbers by I don't work
because now my phone says oh it's your
mom calling
great so that number has been translated
by my phone to a label mom or jane doe
or whoever and we don't know this number
but we should because we go to it
everyday
this is the NCBI server at the National
Library of Medicine which has pubmed so
we're on this particular number a whole
lot but when we type in google when we
when we google the word
pubmed this is actually the number that
were hitting so each database server has
a number it's an IP number
and we no longer understand that number
exists but believe me it does and Phil
born here in this particular perspective
has told us that essentially each of the
items needs this kind of number data
software narratives all sorts of things
must be uniquely identified they must be
shareable because this is how computers
talk to one another and so identifier
'he's over paper identifier of us
identifier of items within the paper
really can tell you a whole lot that
free text or you know beautiful prose
may not be able to tell you if your
computer so we have some nice example
skirt RS 1586 nine is a step inside
inside of the packaging and the NCBI tax
on 96 06 corresponds to human so if
these two identifier Tsar actually
inside of a particular paper a machine
can tell you that this paper references
a cancer-causing step in human now if
you're reading one paper not a big deal
you can probably read that but it turns
out that about a million papers are
published every year in pubmed more than
a million now actually
which ones do you really want to read
is there some way that we can know
better about which ones we want to read
maybe there are some colleagues that you
didn't know you had from another part of
the world we actually might need to get
some assistance from Syrian like robots
you no sirree helps me navigate my way
through different parts of different
cities tells me which restaurants are
reasonable or within a particular price
range
why can't see really helped me find good
papers and permit so stable unique our
date identifiers are ways that we can
actually start to understand papers
publications free text
without doing a whole lot of data
wrangling usually curators and data
Wranglers turn text and data into linked
data objects by adding these kind of
identifiers but anyone can do this
so for example orchid is a researcher ID
if you do not have your orchid i would
highly recommend that you type or get
into google and you try to find that
because orchids our way to disambiguate
you know that the John Smith's that the
wings of the world and and even people
like myself I certainly have an orchid
and I put all of my papers into might
work it into my orchid record so that I
understand you know what is my
intellectual output and I would
encourage again everyone to do the same
grants numbers are another type of
number and i know that NIH has been
asking on for very long time about
making sure that we get the grant
numbers and we put those in properly and
they go into PubMed because then they
can ask very straightforward questions
what has been produced out of this
particular funding mechanism
what is that the paper what is the data
that has been produced so these are
things to tag a particular paper do I is
a way again to tag a particular paper
just like PubMed ID those are both nice
identifier 'he's gene ideas will tag
things inside of papers snap ideas will
tag things inside of papers and those
those kind of ideas actually
disambiguate what it is that the author
is saying we have another type of ID
called the RIT which tags the research
resources the antibody cell lines
organism stocks of a particular paper
again so that you can ask fairly simple
questions which gene where you're really
talking about which snip is that is it
this particular code on or is this code
on we don't know that unless we actually
put in a snip ID for our ids antibodies
we all know that antibodies are really
hard to find inside of papers but an
identifier
our ID when you look that up added to
your paper it starts to become linked
open data that paper starts to and
essentially add to the total amount of
knowledge about that particular reagent
about that particular cell line and we
know that this is one of that again the
big pushes to disambiguate some of the
things that are inside of papers and to
make them more understandable
ok so now we can talk a little bit about
the clothes world versus open-world
these are assumptions that are being
made by databases and database assumes
especially relational database assumes
that the answer to your question is
inside of the database
this is what's called the closed world
assumption
how much money do i have in the bank you
have X amount of money in the bank and
that is the kind of question that
database is really really good at
answering now if I want to know all
genes related to parkinson's disease
that's a little bit of different
question right that's a biological
question and it assumes that the answer
would be most likely not in a database
certainly not in one database maybe not
even in the totality of all of the
databases out there so the literature
actually covers a small part of all
biological knowledge and traditional
databases still even with the multitude
of these databases only cover a small
part of that what's known and literature
so when we asked databases big
open-world questions which really are
biological questions we might be running
into some assumption problems because we
want to know as biologists the
open-world things but databases are very
very good at telling us about the
clothes world about the world that's
inside of the database
so exploration and visit visualization
it's not actually completely useful but
let's see how close we can get to an
open world with some of the bigger
databases with some of the warehouses
so when we start to look at data
analysis and we start to explore it what
sorts of things that you can do when we
have a lot of data put together and this
is one of the gap analyses that we did
with with the neuroscience information
framework data so each of these columns
actually represents a single database
and some of them obviously have more
data
some of them have less data so they add
that the darker the green the more the
data and and then here in this
particular column there's a whole slew
of labels and now each of these labels
is related to the brain and in fact some
of them are like are actually linked to
forebrain some of them are midbrain and
some of them are hind brain structures
so we understand that and there's that
the size of the magnitude of the data so
when we look across all data sources so
this is is a around a hundred and
some-odd different data sources and and
we say well what do we know about any
structure in the forebrain vs any
structure in the midbrain and any
structure in the library and do we know
more about forebrain midbrain it turns
out and that if you then count up the
total number of data points that are
essentially known about the forebrain it
turns out to be much much larger than
the data points known about the midbrain
and you know when we look at
connectivity matrices in in the brain
it turns out that the midbrain is
actually really highly connected
so we should know more about it but when
we look at the data we don't know as
much about it as we do about for brain
structures so because we have an
ontology because we have an ontology
where we know what we should know and
because we have a lot of different
databases all-in-one system we can
actually know what is labeled what is a
part of the data structure i'm in each
of those particular databases then we
can actually start to do a gap analysis
which is where should we look
perhaps the midbrain would be a great
place to look because we there isn't as
much data covering membrane structures
and they're likely very important so we
can do a lot of other fun things and
there's a concept of a homunculus in in
neuroscience and the homunculus is the
representation of the body on the brain
so each animal has a representation of
the skin of the body and we know that
when we actually redraw this
representation of the body it's not
exactly proportional to the skin that
actually covers it so we know that and
the lips the tongue the hands the
fingers are very very well represented
in the brain so they're drawn in a
homunculus as very large whereas you
know the back and the the stomach are
actually very small compared to the
amount of brain bridge at the amount of
brain that actually covers and
understanding and end and processing of
information from say the lips so there
is a homunculus in data so each of these
points if we look at each of these
points and on this particular graph is a
term it's a disease term like
Alzheimer's and there's lots and lots of
disease terms because there's an
ontology so it's very long list of all
sorts of disease terms and so what we've
asked is let's look at all of the
firms across all of the databases and
let's plot that versus reporter now
reporter gives us an idea of what grants
have been funded and they also cover
disease terms right so it turns out and
now i have identified correlation on
this but it looks pretty darn good that
if you fund it and data will come
so it turns out that and if there are
grants that are actually funded to to
look at a particular disease you tend to
get more data points so the data points
are here and the number of grants funded
are here so that kind of tells us that
what we find is actually a very very
important in terms of what we see in the
data space and I want to hit this one
more time on comprehensive indices are
usually the most critical to biologists
so one such comprehensive index is the
antibody registry this has about 2.5
million antibodies which is about is as
many antibodies as we can probably get
to their certainly something's missing
but but it's something that's being
worked on
but you can ask certain questions such
as well let's see what all the different
genes are and this is running the 30,000
human genes this is downsampled and
across any results from the antibody
registry so how many antibodies are
therefore most genes turns out for about
half of the genes we actually have
between 1100 antibodies so there's
pretty good coverage of this type of
reagent for anything you might want to
hit some of the pseudogenes and that the
predicted genes have not been covered
but most of the genome is very well
covered by lots and lots of reagents and
so fun things that we can know
ok so databases really provide structure
data and therefore they can tell us what
data is available warehouses start
actually show places where there is no
data but what if we don't have a
database to cover the thing that we want
to know about what if there's only text
well this is where we would get into
natural language processing and a talk
in about five weeks so natural language
processing is a hold field of computer
science I deal with artificial
intelligence computational linguistics
and it's very very concerned with and
interactions between computers and human
languages so remember your second-grade
teacher your third grade teacher major
do these diagrams of sentences
well it turns out that computer
scientists have been able to Train
computers to do so had I known that I
could have cheated in second grade maybe
I would have done it but now there are
lots and lots of different methods the
Stanford parser and others are available
on to researchers that would like to
figure out how to diagram sentences
there are also a lot of statistical
algorithms like lda and others that
actually show which part of a particular
passage which part of a paragraph is
more important than the other parts so
they kind of pull out keywords and so
what I wanted to show you is just a
couple of examples on how this is being
used today inside of biological
databases so one of the issues with
functional fMRI functional magnetic
resonance imaging studies is that
everyone tries to tell us which parts of
the brain lit up which parts use up more
more glucose when a particular task is
being done so now there's a lot of
people who do this kind of work and they
all try to tag these different parts of
the brain but getting that information
into a database is actually relatively
difficult and a and really
time-consuming
so nerve center talionis database is
actually utilized a lot of text mining
in order to make this process much
faster and simpler and create a complete
data set not maybe as accurate as some
of the human curated but certainly it's
complete because it houses all of the
papers and it it basically gets two
papers into the database very very
quickly so what it does is it removes a
lot of that the attack coordinates for
the particular places in the brain where
and the activation is and is actually
being reported and then it does a bunch
of text mining and statistical analysis
to figure out which are the most
important terms in that particular text
and that are being that are being
discussed
so here is an example for working memory
and now working memory has about 900 one
studies that have been reported on it
and towels work essentially shows that
this particular term is most relevant to
the particular fmri images and then he
reports this onto it onto a human brain
which is great so here the activation
from side for these 901 studies and
actually do cluster so even though the
data is coming from all kinds of papers
and even those is all computer-generated
data the computer is actually pulling
all of these 901 papers he didn't have
to do this and manually but what happens
is we can actually see a pretty good
clustering of what are the sorts of
things that are being reported about
working memory on the brain and some of
the other applications well there is a
program called to express oh and
expresses very cool and there are lots
of other tools that can actually do this
they're somewhat commercial
and but this this kind of gives you an
idea of what are some of the other
things that text mining can do so when
we have text we can diagram sentences we
can figure out what's in now we can
figure out what's it what's a verb
cetera but we can also do is we can
figure out what are the terms inside of
that particular paper that are relevant
to me and i can ask questions such as
give me all sentences expresso that you
know about which lists Parkinson's and a
brain area now I'm asking for any brain
area
I'm not asking for the word brain area
if you type this into google you will
get brain area Parkinson's but what
you're really asking is i want
Parkinson's disease and tell me which
brain areas do you know are most
relevant to it so here's a sentence one
of the the many hits and that the text
press ok and here is a match for a
sentence Parkinson's and talks about the
substantia [ __ ] pars compacta now how
do we know that the substantia [ __ ]
pars compacta is a brain area well
remember back to show you that ontology
well the ontology says substantial [ __ ]
pars compacta is part of brain so it is
a brain area so what we can do is we can
have large lists of of terms that are
related to a particular thing we want to
know like brain area gene expression
type etc etc etc so there are large look
up lists which we can actually feed into
a text a text analysis system to light
up the kinds of things that we might
want to know about particular sentences
again we're producing papers at a
million papers per year
something needs to help us sort through
a lot of this data
and systems such as a text mining
systems are actually starting to get
pretty good and are able to show us some
of the things that we might not
otherwise no
so with that what i wanted to do is I
wanted to thank you very much for
listening for tuning in
thank you for the opportunity to talk to
you all and I hope you tune in for the
rest of the series
thank you so much dr. bent Roeske we are
out of time now so we won't be able to
take questions but I think that's okay
because you are so incredibly clear on
this and we all really appreciate this
talk on so well thank you very much and
to everyone out there listening thanks
for tuning in and we will see you next
week bye